hi there steve kaufman here um today i
want to talk about
return on investment or efficiency in
language learning
so what do i mean by return on
investment well when we learn a language
we invest mostly time and money
we also invest our passion and our our
feelings and and
our sense of commitment and so forth but
those are harder to measure if we look
at
money
and time
let me show you what i consider to be
where i get the best return on
investment
all right so
let's take romanian because that's the
most recent language that i've decided
to learn which i started up on about
five weeks ago
so i bought uh at first we had no
romanian at link i went out and bought
pimsleur it cost me 25 or 30 dollars i
listened to it to it once so while i i
have said that i think it's a good
uh icebreaker into the language
uh i can't listen to it again because
there's too much english i don't like
being prompted to speak
uh
you know i i didn't learn all the words
that are in that first pimsleur
recording but i'm not interested in
going over and over and over the same
questions about do i want to eat do i
want to drink
uh do i understand romanian and so forth
so to me that's a relatively poor return
on investment it becomes a much better
return on investment if you borrow it
from the library
now the second thing i did was i found i
had an old copy of teach yourself i
didn't have it here i've teach yourself
kicking around without a cd so i started
reading through that
then i went to the library and borrowed
teach yourself with the cd so i was able
to listen and read
again the cds i only listened to once
because again there's english on them
the book however
is quite a useful there's a better
return on investment in the book because
i am constantly referring back to the
book
and i'll explain why in a second the
third thing i did is i went on the
internet and i saw that there was a
thing called complete romanian available
on amazon so i ordered it it's also from
teach yourself but i believe that with
these starter books
it's actually quite a good return on
investment to cover the same material
from different angles
so i thought this would be a different
book but much to my disappointment
i discovered that what teach yourself
markets as complete romanian is
absolutely identical
to what they call teach yourself so now
i paid
again for something that i already had
that is i had the book and the cds i
could get from the library and i've
returned them so i don't need them
anymore so
that was kind of a waste of money but
the reason why these little books are
quite handy is
that first of all you have the little
dialogues which after a while get a bit
tiring but
they do have a number of grammatical
explanations with lots of examples and i
find myself constantly rereading these
examples and picking up on stuff
and the other useful thing in these is
you can go to the back of the book
and there they have the answers to the
questions now i don't do the questions
because i just don't like doing them and
i'm not convinced that it's that useful
to be forcing my brain to try to
remember stuff but here you can see
the uh you know the answers to questions
so typically it'll deal with one issue
pronouns or a certain tense or something
so again you'll get 10 examples
of that in use and of course when you
look at these things
you know they you think they're making
an impact on you when you're looking at
them you very quickly forget them and so
it's useful to go back and look at them
again so i find that having some kind of
a starter book
is a good return on investment
whether it be teach yourself pimsleur
whatever your preference is some kind of
a starter book that you can constantly
refer back to
not that you remember the explanations
but it helps you become again to notice
the language better so i think there's a
good return on investment
uh another thing of course is uh
um the internet is so a return on
investment computer absolutely mp3
player absolutely
uh for romanian
i went to elance as i've said which is
this website for outsourcing and i found
people in romania who would record these
150
uh example sentences of some of the more
common patterns of what i want to say in
romanian why because when uh therefore
uh
you know wood should good all the
different types of things that you're
gonna come across so i got a whole bunch
of these translated
into romanian and recorded for me and so
i was spending a fair amount of time
listening to these simple sentences that
illustrate the basic patterns of the
language now that's pretty expensive to
do
that's quite expensive to do it becomes
more cost effective
if i can share these
with uh other learners so for example at
link if we had a lot of people studying
romanian which we don't
then uh
although i have put these up on link
as lessons and you know they've been
studied by 25 30 different people and
again on link i will eventually get
points every month that people are using
these i get points which i can use for
learning other languages so that so to
that extent that investment i can
amortize
by having other people uh you know also
share in them
uh so that was effective the other thing
that i did in uh every so often i lose
my screen here
the other thing that i did uh was uh i
found radio romania which has um
excellent podcasts both the daily news
as well as podcasts on history so i
again through elance got
some romanians to help me
uh transcribe these
uh so that i could read them and have a
better chance of understanding them and
again import them in the link and save
them and so forth and so on again that's
not cheap because you're paying
you know 15 20 20 the different quotes
that i got the cheapest was 15 per audio
hour
and then when they did it they found
that it was just too difficult to do you
really have to find someone who's an
expert transcriber who can do it very
quickly which is what we do for some
other languages where we have people who
are who are very good and who charge
charges quite reasonable rates for
transcribing here again because i don't
have permission from radio romania to
share these in our library
even assuming that there are people who
want to study them at link
i can't share them so i can't amortize
my cost
uh
what i've now found is that in on the
radio romania
website if i poke around i can find bits
and pieces that are transcribed and so i
just use those and hope that what i'm
listening to eventually i'll find
something that has actually been
transcribed
um so again the return on investment on
doing those kinds of things where you're
getting people to record things for you
or transcribe things for you is better
if you have a lot of people sharing
in that
uh also things to invest in
uh obviously okay you've got an mp3
player i have several on the go i've got
my little nano which is the latest one
but i also have
my older nano and this has the advantage
that i can put it in a dock
uh so that if i'm exercising i don't
have to wear my earphones i'm not
convinced that wearing earphones all the
time is so good for you
these are the ones that i use when i go
jogging
uh at one point i had the kind of plug
right into your ear but i find them
not very good for my ear and i and i
think one has to be a little bit careful
about how often you have stuff plugged
into your ear
then i went out and got
these uh bluetooth this is about 70
that's an expensive set extremely
comfortable i think it's important the
sound quality is very good it's a
bluetooth um you know uh earphone
uh
thing and therefore i don't get my
my wire snag like if i'm doing the
dishes every time i turn around i snag
if i have my uh headphone on it'll snare
on one of the you know knobs or
something and it goes falling to the
ground it's quite annoying
so i bought those after i had these
in other words i don't mind investing a
bit of money in good listening equipment
because it's very important to be
comfortable when you're listening and to
not obviously not do damage to your ears
uh i should also mention yeah i mean i
have we all have i have my iphone or
whatever people have blackberry android
and there again that's kind of like an
extension because i can do um all of my
listening mp3 on this if i want
and i can also read using ilink which is
our
link app for iphone ipad
which reminds me that i also have
an ipad
and
you know i regularly read like often
i'll i'll just uh save my links
on the computer because it's more
convenient to do it that way but then i
actually read the text and point at the
different
words that i have saved
uh or listen to it on my ipad
um
what else can i say yeah so all of these
investments
are a relatively good return
on investment of money and even time
uh i'm not sure whether my time is best
spent like i don't spend that much time
reviewing little grammar rules and
patterns and examples in the grammar
book
because i feel that that i get more out
of hearing or identifying or noticing
those patterns
when i'm listening to interesting
content
so i'm actually stealing time away
from that
continuous exposure and immersion to
you know meaningful and interesting
content i'm taking time away from that
to look at these rules and stuff so i
tend only to do that in short spurts you
know i'll leave a book around the on the
bathroom for example
um another uh source here again along
the idea of going at things from
different angles i was sent this
romanian
grammar by a friend
and it's in tremendous detail
no exercises no drills thank you very
much that's what grammar books should be
grammar a quick explanation of the rule
this is what happens in the language ten
examples and and that's all you need no
drills questions fill in the blanks
multiple choice you name it and so this
is another excellent source so with this
it's basically going through the same
material
the same basic patterns of the language
as you find in the teach yourself book
but it's another uh
approach at it
and uh slightly different presented
slightly differently with different
examples
so all of these i think even if you add
it up i mean there's some obviously some
of these tools like the ipad the iphone
the mp3 player the earphones those you
can use for a number of different
languages uh if you buy a teach yourself
or something or if you pay someone to
transcribe or record things for you
then uh you know that's um
for that specific language there you
want to be able to share the cost around
there are sites on the internet like
rhino spike where you can get stuff
recorded uh
we and i think uh when it comes to
correcting text lang 8 does that we at
link are going to significantly
facilitate this whole idea of of
exchange of services related to language
learning uh you can look for that within
the next
you know three four weeks that'll be
happening at link
and i think you know to the extent that
people can help each other that's a a
great return on
on time and and on money uh so you take
all of that there there could be uh
you know between the ipad the iphone and
earphones and and uh
getting people to do stuff you're up to
a thousand dollars not all of which is
specific to that one language
now you compare that to people who come
to vancouver for example to learn
english
um oh one thing i also do is i have a
couple of tutors so i have
uh essentially four i have two romanian
tutors uh
i do a half hour on tuesday
with one and a half hour on thursday
with the same person and then i do a
half hour with another tutor on tuesday
and on thursday one at eight o'clock in
the morning one at 11 o'clock in the
morning so i'm getting in basically two
hours a week of interaction with the
tutor
uh which again costs money
but if you compare all of that to going
to a school
uh for example people who come to
vancouver who have to come here they
have to stay with a host family there's
a thousand bucks a month or whatever it
is
uh and then they go to school there's
another thousand bucks a month
the reality of language learning is that
it takes time
and so whether you're going to a class
or not going to a class it's still going
to take a lot of time
uh i
doubt that if i had gone to a romanian
class
uh
and spent whatever a thousand fifteen
hundred two thousand dollars a month i
don't think i would have learned any
faster than i'm learning now
because when you're learning on your own
using these resources you go to the
grammar book when you feel like it you
listen to what you feel like listening
to when you feel like doing it
you're more mobile independent and i
think you learn just as fast or faster i
mean if i have a total of
basically two hours which i can step to
step up to three hours a week of
intensive one-on-one with my romanian
tutor and who uses the linked system in
other words
the tutor will write down 10 15 20
phrases that i misused i get them and i
import them as content to study within
link and i save the words and phrases
and so i get one of the advantages of
that approach or of you know having
something like the teach yourself book
or another grammar book around is you go
back to it again and again and again so
you're not making a one-off investment i
think in all of these investments you
want to invest in things that you can go
back to again and again and again so
even with the things that i've had
transcribed or that i have recorded i
can use them again and again and again
one of the difficulties with a classroom
situation is you pay every month and
that's gone so
i'm not against schools
because everyone has a different way of
learning
but i think when it comes to a return on
investment given that it's it's a long
process
that one should be a little careful
about how how you know how you spend
your money and so i think everyone needs
to do their own evaluation of what
represents a good return on investment
for them when it comes to language
learning so there you have it a bit of a
ramble
usu
disorganized as usual but this time on
the subject of efficiency or a return on
investment in language learning thank
you for listening